vous avez témoigné sur les pressions et
parfois les menaces que vous pouvez
recevoir ta dernière en date c'est que
lorsque vous étiez tranquillement en
terrasse en famille donc je vous aimez
vous avec votre femme et votre fille
absolument en terrasse non voilà en
train de déjeuner et là il ya même fort
prenez un café il ya un type qui
s'approche et me dit vous êtes un
collabo un collabos collabos d'un régime
dictatorial
faut vous arrêtez de parler on devrait
vous empêcher de parler et puis un jour
le jour venu on vous retrouvera et et
vous paierez alors c'est pas tellement
le fait se faire insulter parce que se
faire insulter ça arrive on peut avoir
des débats vifs on en a eues ici
ça c'est pas le souci c'est l'idée qu'
il y aurait un jour un espèce de grand
soir une sorte de grand soir qui ferait
que tous les pros science parce que je
dis pas provoque son nez plutôt pro
science serait arrêtée jugée complice de
criminels et pour apprécier ans a laissé
le finir et c'est le fait n'est
défini des choses
sans merci je suis très près très
franchement me suis remarié rien
palombes ratio pay laisser parler les
autres ce que sinon on va pas y arriver
donc laissé par des tirs y ait laissé le
film voilà c'est l'idée c'est michel
gilbert jours
le gouvernement qui est quand même juste
élu démocratiquement serait renversé et
qu on serait tous ceux arrêtés jugés
comme des criminels de guerre d'ailleurs
sur rien des internautes qui m'a envoyé
une liste je suis sur la liste des
grands criminels et collaborateurs avec
olivier ferrand avec daniel cohn bendit
à claude malhuret avec le président de
la république et je suis en 19e position
10 navale sur le mur des criminels et
des collabos c'est ça qui me gêne c'est
pas encore une fois à myriam c'est pas
le débat vif qui me gêne ça ça me gêne
pas
c'est l'idée de dire qu' on est
collaborateur de criminels de guerre
mais vous qui avait appelé qui avait
appelé que qu'avait dit sur les
émissions d'estelle denis qu'il fallait
pourrir la vie des non abonnés qu'ils
étaient des connards ici alors le mot
canada
alors il va nous expliquer tirailleurs
c'est cet extrait qu'il faut pour rendre
la vie invivable
oh non vaccinés je suis pour pourrir la
vie des non vaccinés ça veut dire quoi
pourrir la vie ça veut dire les ont pu
restreindre les djs avec jacques chirac
tient trois tests par semaine on va déjà
s'est pas fait excusez moi mais y'en a
ras-le-bol que les non vaccinés nous
pourrissent la vie on a une arme à notre
disposition et il ya une minorité deux
connards qui ne veulent pas se faire
mais non non non je me résolus bien mais
chacun est maître des céans son portable
alors changé j'ai su contrarier qu'elle
parlait quand je donne ma parole sinon
on n'y arrive pas alors juste après j'ai
retiré mon mot connard en disant
qu'effectivement c'était un petit peu
outrancier et en revanche j'ai dit que
vous étiez d irresponsable et je ne
retire aucun mot à part le mot canard de
ce que j'ai dit là parce que je pense
qu'il faut pourrir la vie des non
vaccinés je suis vraiment pas ce que
c'est vous qui nous pourrissent la vie
en fait aujourd'hui on vise alors on va
on va en parler thierry parce que myriam
est là vous avez fait ce tweet on t'a
club est tranquillement en famille à la
terrasse d'un café parisien un homme
s'approche et me dit ce que vous nous
avez dit vous êtes un collabo le collabo
d'un régime dictatorial et myriam a
réagi elle a mis en même temps vous avez
voulu leur envoyer des brigades pour
qu'ils se fassent vacciner de force
alors cessé de faire la victime façon
député la république en marche la
violence engendre la violence et c'est
vous qui l'avez déclenché alors vous par
exemple guillaume genton vous êtes vous
trouvez que vous cautionnez les propos
de myriam oui parce qu est ce que c'est
normal de recevoir des menaces non mais
est ce que c'est normal d'insulter des
millions de français sur un plateau
c'est pas normal non plus et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui quand on est médiatisé
quand on est dans une émission qui
regardaient comme c'est votre cas par
des centaines de milliers de
téléspectateurs
il faut mesurer l'impact de ce qu'on dit
et je pense qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont
pas votre tribune des gens qui ont
l'opinion de mme irène par exemple qui
ne peuvent pas s'exprimer parce qu'on
sait qu'ils sont sous représentés dans
les médias et je comprends qu'il puisse
mal le prendre et qu'ils puissent à leur
tour avoir des mots très durs contre
vous donc moi je soutiens mes rêves je
suis d'accord avec elle voilà au miriam
alors thierry il dit pourrir la vie des
vestes et des noms vous pourrit la vie
abba super sauf que non mais j'aimerais
qu'on vienne sur cet échange ou là bas
mais je reviens justement sur cet
échange alors moi je vais pas au resto
en quoi je vous pourrit la vie enfin les
non-vaccinés vont pas au resto ne
peuvent plus faire d'activités en quoi
on vous pourrit votre vie en quoi on
vous pourriez vous dit par contre vous
vous faites des appels à la haine sans
cesse alors moi jouent en quoi les
non-vaccinés vous avez eu un cas d'une
personne qui est venu vous voir en quoi
les non vaccinés les gens non le
défendent leur lit qui veulent défendre
mais moi aussi j'en ai moi aussi on
n'arrête pas de m'attaquer et alors en
quad en quoi ces gens comme comme moi
comme moi qui n'ont même plus accès à
des choses simples de la vie courante
vous pourriez vous avez choisi et alors
là vous avez choisi de vous de vous
vacciner très bien vous êtes contents
vous allez au restaurant café il n'y a
pas assez de gens vaccinés jaoui
d'accord y amasser alors faut quand même
savoir c'est notamment sur les paris on
ne peut plus cool ici la population
c'est quoi c'est pas excessive des
musées myriam ce qui me gêne myriam
c'est que les gens comme vous vous
n'arrêtez pas de dire qu'on vit dans une
dictature sanitaires si on était
vraiment dans une dictature mademoiselle
vous seront les ailes major vous seriez
soit en prison au mieux dans une vraie
dictature est ce que vous aimeriez
activement pour mieux une police
politique vous aurez éliminé en émoi
aujourd'hui je peux plus amené mes
enfants dans des centres aérés type
disneyland à parc astérix etc je ne peux
plus rien faire avec mes enfants je ne
peux plus aller au respect
non je ne me fatiguerai pas pour je ne
vais pas sortir des chiffres puisque
vous me l'interdisait non non on n'est
pas dans le jeu mais est ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est ce que les cheminées
chiffres sur lesquels vous vous basez
pour dire ça sont complètement faux il
suffit juste de regarder les comment
s'appellent les rapports de l'adresse ou
de santé publique donc déjà d'une
rencardez vous là d'ssus vous êtes
journaliste à la base même si comme moi
vous avez fait de la ce people je pense
que voilà vous avez l'habitude de 2,2 de
vous regarder juste mais oui voilà vous
avez été à ici paris un magazine que je
dirige un d'ailleurs et vous allez
commencer à voir là-bas tunis voilà donc
je ne vois pas je ne comprends pas en
quoi nous qui ne pouvait plus rien faire
et qu avons fait ce choix et qui en plus
moi par exemple je fais beaucoup d'auto
test pour pas contaminer les gens